what do you learn about human nature by
looking at
the history of slavery in america
oh my so what does that tell you about
people
well
i think of two things right off the top
of my head
one is about the capacity
of people
for
looking the other way in the face of
uh unethical and uh
you know morally
profoundly problematic
practice
so i mean slavery was controversial it
was controversial
going all the way back to the founding
of the united states of america the
country was founded on a compromise
where
half of the country
thought that slavery was
was abhorrent and would not have had it
uh countenanced
in the constitution the other half of
the country were
steeped in the dependence on the labor
of these african captives
and their descendants the economy
depended upon it they owned them as
property that was their wealth their
wealth was invested to some degree in
the value of these
human beings
and in order for the united states to
come together as a confederation of the
several colonies
there had to be a compromise made and it
was made
where slavery was allowed to persist
uh and uh the people who were against it
or who thought it morally problematic
were able to countenance
the practice in the southern
states where slavery flourished and that
went on for 75 years after the founding
of the country until the crisis of the
late 1850s that led to the civil war and
ultimately to the emancipation so one
thing
i think about human nature
from the fact of slavery is that
the ability of people to live with
terrible
morally
questionable practices and have that as
a part of their institutions
it took a
movement of a massive movement of
abolitionists
uh struggling against slavery
for the better part of a century
before
um before that that practice could be
eradicated
but the other thing about human nature
uh that i see
is the ability of people
to sustain
their humanity under the most
awful oppressive conditions
um
the enslaved persons the slaves
um and their children i mean they were
chattel they were bought and sold like
horses or or cattle
um and yet
uh they were not their humanity was not
destroyed by that and
they were able to
sustain their
dignity
to some degree in such a manner that
once emancipation
finally did arrive the
friedman and women the the persons who
had been
enslaved and who were set free
were able to
over the
following
decades
uh build a foundation uh for the
development of african americans within
the context of american society
that eventually culminated in the civil
rights movement of the middle of the
20th century
and uh has led us into the present day
so
uh
you know
human nature can countenance awful evil
but human nature can also survive in the
face of terrible evil
that's what i take from
slavery that's survival
that flame can burn even when uh
this the world around it tries to put it
out this there's still a little flame of
human consciousness of spirit of culture
of whatever the hell that is that makes
humans flourish and makes humans
beautiful that lives on
that's everyone said yeah i think you
you put it very well there's got to be
some
poetic way of expressing that
leave it to the poets yeah
what about the people that look the
other way
how many people do you think
just regular people
knew that something is this is wrong
or did do people
through generations convince themselves
most people most regular people convince
themselves that there's nothing wrong
all right
yeah
i asked this question because i wonder
what we're looking the other way on
today also
because
you mean you have to kind of if we're
you have to ask yourself these difficult
questions of assuming we're the same
people we were yeah back then
then we're
we can be flawed in that same kind of
way we can look the other the other way
just as others have
in history
yeah and
you spoke of the european uh context and
of the nazis and um
certainly
a lot of people had to be looking the
other way
when the massive crimes that were
committed by that regime were being
undertaken i mean the railroad cars full
of human
beings being taken off to be slaughtered
or to be worked to death in
labor camps or they'd be gassed
etc a lot of people had to know about
what was going on and
looked the other way
or enthusiastically supported the
the persecution of the jews and the
gypsies and
so on
and i don't know i wasn't you know i
wasn't around in 1840
my sense of the matter is that like of
many practices that are unjust most
people thought
that's just the way it is i mean that's
the world that they inherited they they
they were not moralists they were not
revolutionaries
they they just wanted to go along
uh some people might have been troubled
by it but thought there's nothing that
can be done some people might have
thought well
they're
these black africans they're not really
like us and you know they are lucky to
be here if they were in africa they'd be
worse off still
some people might have thought that
uh some people might have been disturbed
but not been able to see what it is that
they could do about it
uh they they might have thought oh this
is
you know this is disgusting this is
uh you know not something i wouldn't
want to have anything to do with but
uh not knowing whether there's any
practical way of opposing it that that's
why
you need a movement you need
for the people who are
troubled by the practice to know that
there are others like themselves equally
troubled and
as they gather together
collectively they can exert their
their influence i mean debates about the
the wrongness of slavery as i say go all
the way back to the founding of the
country
there were abolitionists and there were
people who were who opposed the
compromise that led to the
uh framing
documents and
institutions that created the united
states of america opposed the
countenancing of
slavery in that in that situation
um but it took a while before that could
come to
come to a head
and
produce the crisis which ultimately led
to the eradication of slavery i would
note that
uh slavery is not unique to the united
states it's not unique to the western
hemisphere
that enslavement of people the
trafficking in human
channel
uh is something that one sees in on on a
global basis one sees it going all the
way back to
antiquity
so we might ask how is it that people
finally came
to turn their backs and eradicate the
practice that that might be the thing
worth
really trying to understand because the
practice itself is
you know there's a wonderful book
by the sociologist orlando patterson
called slavery and social death
that was published in 1982
uh which is a comprehensive history and
social analysis of the institution of
slavery
over
2500 years
going back to the classical greek and
roman civilizations
finding slavery in africa amongst
africans finding slavery in the middle
east finding slavery in the far east
finding slavery in south asia
the enslavement of people
the practice of taking someone as a
captive in war and then instead of
killing them which you could do
making them into your property
was a very very widespread
in human culture
so i mean i i'd like to make this point
sometimes when we people are talking
about how wrong slavery was and i agree
without any question
uh that the practice was uh profoundly
morally
uh problematic
but i like to make the point that
given how wrong it was
think about how
impressive was the accomplishment of the
eradication of slavery now that was
something there were 600 000 dead
in the war between the states 1861 to
1865 in a country of 30 million people
that's a that's a lot of dead people
uh
who gave their lives not to eradicate
slavery and in every instance probably
most of them were just
fighting for uh you know
they enlisted or were
conscripted into the forces and they
fought and they died but the net effect
of their having fought and died uh was
to
push along a process that led to the
eradication of slavery that's an amazing
achievement
uh the slaves themselves
were
largely
uneducated and uh you know backward in
there
of course what else could they have been
they they were kept in captivity they
were
prevented from
developing their human potential and yet
uh after the end of slavery that
population that four million plus
african descended people
uh became the foundation for what a
century later
leads to martin luther king standing in
the washington mall
and giving that great speech and now
here we are 150 years down the road and
barack obama is president of the united
states now he did not descend from
slaves i think we must not lose track of
that
but he identified as an african-american
and was a part of the population
that consisted largely of people who
descended from slaves
and
we are we african americans are
for all practical purposes
fully equal citizens of this great
republic that has happened within a
century and a half
and i don't know that you can find any
parallel to that kind of
transformation and the status of people
from human chattel
to full citizens of the republic
anywhere in human history it's certainly
worth celebrating the achievement of the
eradication of slavery i would say
and it probably started with a few
people
that
inside their mind dared to rebel
you know it's interesting to think about
how it all started
how
in the state of injustice
the
the revolution percolates
like where it starts you said people
that see something is wrong find each
other
it's you know
it's in the ideas of charismatic
individuals that not only know that
something is wrong but they're able to
tell others about it and be uh
convincing
and then together gather
and rise up it's interesting to make
this kind of incredible progress from
slavery to where we are today to live
out the ideal of this all men accreted
created equal
um
yeah the power of individual because i i
don't i don't know what you think about
it but i tend to think that
a few small individuals
probably originated this like it's the
power of the individual because
sometimes we think there's injustice in
the world what can i possibly do
i tend to think one person can
be the seed
of starting to fix the injustice
sure
one person here one person there
yeah
um one thinks of course of
frederick douglass the
massively
significant figure
who was born in slavery
um who uh stole his freedom
and uh because he was property and he he
decided he was not gonna be property
anymore and he took it unto himself to
emancipate himself personally and who
became an educated
uh powerfully
articulate
uh
massively influential person in the
united states and in england
uh going around
presenting himself as uh an embodiment
of
human dignity and
uh uh
the commitment to ideals of equality and
you know i mean he's just one person
but there were others
you